Hey, everyone.
Imagine you've poured time, money and effort into a deal, but just as you're locked in, the other side changes the terms.
And now you can't afford to walk away.
You've just fallen to a classic trap, the post investment holdup.
It starts with sunk cost and ends with regret.
To avoid it, you have to look ahead and reason back.
Sunk costs are past investments you can't recover.
Time, money, labor.  It's all gone.  The mistake?
Letting those costs dictate your future decisions.
Rational thinking says, ignore them.  They're gone.
Good strategy.  Ask what are the next cost and benefits?
Not what have I already spent?
Post investment holdup happens when you commit big upfront and your partner waits until you're stuck to change the deal.
Maybe they raise prices.
Maybe they threaten to walk away unless you renegotiate.
You can't walk away because you've already built the factory, coded the software, and you've gone all in.
We assume the deal won't change.
We assume trust and past agreements will hold.
But the moment your investment is sunk, the power shifts.
They hold the leverage, you hold the risk.
It sounds simple.
Look ahead and reason back.
But it's hard in practice.
Ask yourself, what incentives will my partner have after I commit?
What could they do that hurts me?
Once I'm locked in, would I still do the deal?
Starting from scratch.
Smart partners build in protection before they commit.
Here's how.
Detail contracts.
Define pricing, timelines and dispute resolution before you invest.
A strong contract locks in the terms before power shifts.
Cap pricing to avoid surprise markups.
Set timelines with penalties for delays.
Include clear paths for resolving disputes.
Exchange of hostages.
Each side puts up something valuable, something they lose if they act opportunistically.
Escrow funds, joint intellectual property and mutually valuable deliverables.
Progressive investment.  Don't commit everything at once.
Structure deals and stages tied to progress.
Prototype pilot, full scale.
Each stage unlocks the next, reducing total exposure.
And finally, build exit options.
Keep a plan B in your back pocket.
Write a termination costs.
Vet background partners.
Early use modular systems that can be reused elsewhere.
The goal isn't to avoid investment, it's to avoid regret.
Sunk costs blur your judgment.
Post investment holdup kills your leverage.
So before you commit, look ahead and reason back.
Protect yourself.
Don't build something you can't walk away from.
And that's all we have.
Hope you've enjoyed it.